[Music]
the last two months have been
a dark time for me to be honest and
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's
kind of weird
putting your life out there on the
internet
there are times when i want to share
everything and
there are times when i want to share
nothing at all
i think there's a fine line between
having healthy boundaries and feeling
inauthentic when it comes to posting
your personal life online
and i'm really just learning as i go
but it feels strange pretending like
things are fine when they aren't
creativity is how i process things and
lately i'm finding it hard to hide
behind the art
my emotion
tends to come through in whatever i
create
one way or another
[Music]
i don't think
i'll ever want to talk about this apart
from what i briefly say here
but
i'm alone now
and
i have been
for months
[Music]
nathaniel and i were in a relationship
for almost two years and traveled
together as friends for two years before
that
so it's been hard
and
i'm still processing a lot of it
out here on the road you learn the art
of letting go
letting go of plans and people and
places and things that are just not
meant for you
or right for you
little by little you learn to trust the
madness
[Music]
and
let it guide you someplace new
[Music]
good morning i got some coffee i got
some snacks got gas filled water emptied
my toilet
um
emptied all of my trash cleaned out my
bear band and now i'm hitting the road
i'm heading up to salt lake city because
i need to ship out my canon camera and
lens because the wind knocked it over
the other day which is really sad uh it
might be broken and then i'm heading to
bend oregon
which
i've never been there before
so i've got a 14 hour drive
and
this was totally unplanned i just
decided on a whim to
head west and try out then because i've
never been there before and i've heard
really good things it looks like a great
road life town so i'm excited
[Music]
[Music]
you know that's saying
when it rains it pours
that's kind of how life felt for a
little while
first my camera and lens were busted
when a rogue gust of wind swept through
camp out in utah
so i had to ship off my gear and i just
stopped creating for a little while
then
there was just
grief
and
learning how to be alone again
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
then my electrical system nearly went up
in flames
super melted
i was heating up water like i always do
when i smelled something burning so i
opened the battery cabinet and the
inverter was beeping and the wire was
literally melting into the fuse box look
at how melted these wires are you see
that absolutely fried and then
there were chipmunks i have a chipmunk
squirrel issue
they have been
rumbling around inside my engine
for days and it's kind of making me go
crazy of course it's annoying just
hearing them like
rumble around inside the engine
but i've found evidence that they've
been chewing my engine wires which can
be very costly and destructive
so i've been trying a number of
different things to get them out and i
started with peppermint spray that
didn't work so then i started popping my
hood so that it wasn't like a dark quiet
warm place
they didn't care so then i got online
and i read that you should try
dryer sheets that didn't work i used the
new rodent spray i use these squirrel
balls
an ultrasonic rodent repellent that you
install underneath the hood some people
suggest that i use irish spring soap and
as you can see
they're actually trying to eat it
nothing is working and it's driving me
insane in fact
one of the squirrel balls
i don't even know what happened to it
[Music]
so my latest tactic has been using my
old iphone
was trying to grab him for a
conversation
after catching up with her in the
parking lot i stash it under the hood
with an audiobook playing
and that works somewhat i don't hear
them as frequently i don't think they
like the sound of talking humans last
night my phone died and i woke up to the
sound of all of these rodents just
scurrying around inside of my engine
there's a bike path here and people are
just passing by
they probably think i'm so crazy that's
not the only issue i've been running
into it's been raining for the past
three days off and on and
i discovered a puddle on my counter
kitchen countertop yesterday so i have a
week
that doesn't look right
[Music]
i'm just starting to feel a little
stressed
so when a last-minute pet sit popped up
on the edge of the very same forest i
happened to be camped in
i took it as a sign and applied
[Music]
okay
i love having routine
even if only temporary
i like doing the dishes and vacuuming
the carpets and taking out the trash
watering the plants and walking the dogs
it's
meditative and it's the little things
that give me a reminder of what i'm
missing out on
and allows me to check in with myself
and ask do i want this instead
would this kind of life make me happier
honestly i think i'd be pretty happy
living here
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
usually these house sits are just enough
to remind me that while i do want a home
someday
i'm not ready to give up van life just
yet
only three places have made me think
otherwise and bend is one of them
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
day by day life got a little brighter
[Music]
when it was finally time to leave it
felt like i was both leaving and going
home
nowhere to be
no one to meet
just
me in the open road
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i've spent the last few months exploring
new places
the kind you find on winding dirt roads
and also the kind you find within
looking back on all of it makes me
realize that
if it weren't for creating and sharing
these videos with you
i probably wouldn't have filmed anything
at all
it would have been so much easier to
forget everything about this chapter
to overlook moments of light
in a time that felt so overwhelmingly
dark
but
maybe then i wouldn't be able to see so
clearly the distance i've traveled from
here to where i am now
not just in miles
but
in other ways as well
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i can't really promise you anything
other than the imperfect ever-changing
work in progress that is my life
for now anyway
but i can promise to do my very best to
share whatever beautiful views i happen
to find along the way
[Music]
hi hello editing christian here
uh so there are a few things i wanted to
say that i couldn't quite convey in the
video and i will get to that shortly but
first i want to take a minute to thank
today's sponsor which is storyblocks so
as you guys know i film and edit these
videos and i'm definitely just learning
as i go but i recently added storyblocks
to my workflow storyblocks is an
affordable subscription-based website
that gives you access to unlimited
downloads of over 1 million stock assets
assets are royalty-free and constantly
expanding to include new 4k footage
overlays images templates and pretty
much everything you might need for a
commercial or personal project this
footage for example is from a canadian
national park where it's illegal to fly
a drone without a special permit having
access to assets like this can help you
bring your stories to life without
sacrificing your vision due to time
budget or resources storyblocks is
committed to enabling creators of every
kind through initiatives like restock
which aims to increase representation by
investing in diverse and inclusive
content and also through their
enterprise licensing option which can
cover your entire team or organization
so be sure to check them out by visiting
this link in the description down below
the last two months have been
a dark time for me to be honest and
i
i found it impossible to create anything
from the heart without being up front
creativity is how i process my emotion
and
my intention with this channel was to
have a creative outlet that was less
polished than the photography platforms
i was posting on i want to build a
channel where the only real constant is
change and where it's possible to evolve
and have new interests and do new things
and express whatever i want to express
and i totally understand if some things
resonate and some things don't but
um
it's just nice
but it's nice knowing that you guys show
up for me regardless your support in the
last video like your thoughtful comments
and and sharing your own personal
stories of loss and light with family
members or loved ones was just
i wish that i had the time to
individually respond to each and every
one of you the way i want to
but if i did that i'd be sitting in
front of a computer forever between
editing photography and work and video
and
comments and all the things so i
i just want to say i appreciate you so
much a fair amount of time has passed
between now and the scenes that you just
watched in the video it's been a couple
months so
i'm back in the pnw i'm starting to feel
a little more like myself again
and i have adventures planned like
backpacking hiking van lifeing road
trips that i'm really excited to share
with you all it is so hot right now
because i have all the windows closed
because it's loud outside and i swear
it's like 115 degrees in here right now
but uh that's fan life
you